ultimately it's not hard to imagine a
world dystopian future in which all yes
gab undercut no it's not hard to imagine
a world in which you know content TV
content formerly TV content is delivered
over the Internet and certainly repeats
which are already being delivered over
the Internet are only delivered over the
Internet and sort of the deal that we've
all had all along in the wga and the wga
East which I think we're all in yeah
beside the deal is sort of like we give
you our copyright we create this stuff
we give you our copyright and we get
reimbursed when you use our material and
then a goat you know through history
we've tried to negotiate a fair way to
be reimbursed for our work when it's
repurposed and so what the strike is
about is how we're going to be
compensated for our work and our
copyright being used in the future on
future of platforms it was really good
thank you thank you my the basic fear
would be as things move to digital media
that you'd almost be taking like a pay
cut rather than it's not even yeah it's
not even that but you know it's not even
arguing for a gain its protecting
against a loss of salary if everything
goes digital and there's no longer the
reruns and there's of course the
complicated residual system but that's
basically how people stay afloat when
they're not working or right well plus
it also i mean union like to say that
that that's the reason we have it but
it's also like they're reusing your work
you're getting more money for it I feel
I don't feel any shame in getting more
money when they reuse my work feel shame
that they're showing it I mean if you
should see some of the stuff I've
written mm-hmm we have that's why you're
scabbing this is ivan forced to scab oh
she who smelt it dealt it
really that's that's the level of
writing yeah at this almost dragged
mother are we like the first it is
interesting to for that to really
realize on some level you have no
control over your career how do you
think that that's you know in general
the instant like you reminded of the
instability of your profession yeah that
you even like we've all been chose for a
couple years which is are sometimes like
a long run oh that's but you know you're
reminded that even at a job you know
even at a show that's going you know
that's still going well it's right now
then you can at any time not have a job
yeah but even like even if you're three
of the best comedy writers who have ever
written in medium just you're clean yeah
just with my coming for myself yeah oh
you're the Siam three of those people
you can still not have a job because of
these Union woes well these am PPP woes
and it's funny too because we where I we
just join me if I don't want to make
this a union and low at the same time
yeah mrs. whoa whoa Union whoa um then
it is it does sort of make you cherish
your job so much more I really do like
cherish my job and wish I could be back
there and the people you're working with
it sucks to not see well yeah I touch
them out not see the people you work
with and to know that like I feel so
guilty and that they're the ones you
know it sucks but you know that they
don't have jobs either and that it's
you're talking about the non-work the
below them oh yeah what are called below
the liners yeah well normally like you
will you blow on you yeah you're below
the liner friends no we are we're like
the line with a lot okay where we're
going you live in an ass
I mean I think there has to naturally be
some time like your shows the back both
our shows are back yeah they're all
working okay well but I mean I'm sure
they miss me my sparkling wit but but
there's I've Remy n for I think there's
a helplessness because you would you
would want to just have you know there's
any way they were back and it wasn't
affecting ma'am yeah rights to you in it
you feel like the implications it's not
only you who is suffering for your for
your collective actions but these other
people but I mean I would sucks although
eventually it's clearly going to
implicate a wider audience which people
maybe don't realize is that the get
there the actors and directors are also
going to other but probably strike and
that's gonna it's it's unfortunate the
guild had to go first because it kind of
puts a lot of it on the guild but also
it should be pointed out should be
pointed out that that I mean when the
shows are off the air they're still
putting when new shows are not being
produced because the strike they're
still putting reruns on they're still
making some advertising money from that
and they're not paying the writers
they're not playing the director they're
not paying so my point is that well
depends some right if you're getting
paid something yeah a residual those
shows are being repeated they're making
money they could have supported this the
the producers could have still paid the
staff i think you know i mean the
economics are so they made it seem like
we have to lay them off cuz we're not
making any money you just think i'm
wrong whoa well i think that there's
only so long that i mean if you're in
reruns for two months i clearly yeah
right there making yes financial what
they're paying less money is my point
that's true it would be way more
expensive for them though I mean from a
business stamp know you're ready make
sense but you know good yes yes no
obviously they do better I'm still gonna
take you out Wow how dare you fucking
solidarity just broke down right now I'm
just saying I want to toss my coffee if
they're not if they don't want that step
it definitely made a better point than I
did he take me me Raven you didn't make
it the point I was saying was not China
they made it seem like it was our fault
but they really could have sustained
people longer I think and still not had
a huge deficit my point is if they
wanted to like go out of their way
and take a financial loss sure help
people they would just make the deal we
read it together a montage where we
start arm wrestling and then I'll gang
and not depending I'm just